D
APING UP TO BE
VACCINE  FAUCI.AINST ESPECIALLYO
WE BEGINA RAPIDLY
G SITUATIO
AFGHANISTAN.
PRESIDENT DE TO
END 20 YEAR OF MILITAR
THERE.
TODAY AS THEHIY E TALIBAHE
N THPRESIDENT'RUCTIONS ORDERED P
THE MA A ARMY FORCES,
ABOUT 3,00AL
TASKED WITH ATENCALLS A
REDUCTIOILN PERS
AT THE EMBASSY.
THE THOSENOUGH MIGHTN PARTUR
HE SN
EMBASSY ROOFTOP.
LISTEN TO NED PRICISN TION NOR
TO THEAN.OR ANY KIND O
IS NG RILY IN CONFLICT IN
THIS IS NOT AN EVAIOIS IS NOE
WITHDRAL.WHAT THIS S REDUCTION
ACCELERATING FROM
NOT ONRINK O, IT'SERARTHULAT'S
USUTGOVERNMENT HAS PUT INTTION
ABOUT THE AMERIC EREALLY GOI
OMO WORSE.
12LS NOW UNDER
NTROL OF THE TALIBAN.
AMON THE THIRDCOTRALSO APPEARS .
STRATEGICALLY IMPORTANT
CITY.
ALSO TIRTHAC THE
TALIBAN, SO IT HAS O
SYMBOLISM BEHIND IT.
BECAUSE THEY'RQUICKLY THINGSRE
N TH 2
URR MISSION IS TO SITHE WIDR EM.
THE ATRTMENT WAS TRYING
S NOT
EVACUATION.E EMBASSY ISNING OPE.
THIS IS ABOUT ENDURING
PARTNERSHIP STILL WITH
AFGHANISTAN, BUT ON THE GROUND,
PEOPLE SEE THIASN EVUA
ALLY
NTTH GE ANIC AS THATIO
DETERI
MG IS THERE'SRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG,BO T THE AMERICAN EMBASSY
HOW MANY OF THOSE AR ALD
BE EVACUATED AS
?
>> WELL,HAN
LOT.TION THAT S HEDGED A
DS OF AVE WORKED WITH THE OMND
CAPACITY.
WHO HAVE WORKED WITH T U.
MILITARY IN SOME CTHE AN
GISTIC
IR THAT 1200R SO
NOT KNOWING IF THEY WILLETN PAP
R ES OUT TA OF KANDAHAR BEINOVE.
ST.I TIONS FOR THE UNITED
HELMAN WAS HARBY U.S. MAAT OF K
ITSELF FALLING T MOMENT, THE
SITUATION INABEELEAST POTENTIAL
MOMENT.T COULD CNG
>> THERE'S FRO"THE
TH.
ENJOY HAS BEEN TG TO GET N LEAD
TOKINDT REALLY HOLD UP?
>> SO THE MAIN LEVERAG THE
U.S. HIG AT THE NEGOTIATING TAB,
STRIKES.
BUT THEY ALSEVAG BECOMING AN IN
PARIAH.NT
COMMUNITY TO ACCEPTH ALLE T COUA
HOWEVER, DOES ITEXR ONS ANS FROM
THWHEN POINT
IN TIME, VERY
THEYANS MILITARILYEAT.THEY AREIN
WITHOUT MAKING HUGE CONCESSIONS
TH
AT THE SAME TIME, E TALIBAN  SEG
SO TO MAKEPROMISES TO, YOU PROTE
OR NOT TO .S
EM THEAVE
. MILITA PERNN MIGH F
EXTRACTION, TH IIG
SOMETHT, ANDERSO>>PPIT.ANK YOU.A
KNOWS
ALMOST ANYONE.ASTA
FIRST OF ALL, EACTION TO
THE U.S. S
HE E I TO HELP TCUIO POTENTIALLI
KABUL.
THASO BE DAGINE.
MSNCTHADDOE T , NOT TO DEL A FOR
NOW
RY SAD TO HEAR THATHE, THAT OUR
NOT TO SHOOT AT US AS WE
WHEN YOU T HSTARTED,
MED A REALITY.
THE ITE , S AN
EVACUATIONOF
PERSONL,LSO A NUMBER OF
AFGHANS.
NEON'T KNOHOGOH
ESPECIALLY WITH INTETEOTHERS WRM
THOUSANDS OFHOAVD CLOSRELATIONS.
OBVIOUSLISNTKNOWWE
ELSEWHERE
IRAQHAS A HISTORY  BEHIND. D
EED OF THE
AFGHAN IW, THE FI
EVER GOT THERE IN 02
TYANS WE SAYING,OU
ANDINGP
THE AFGHAN ARMY.
FO'RE POURING RESOURCES INTO IT.
U ACCOR
FAILURE ANTHE TALIBAN  AER MA
R PREST  AUTHORI TIB
WITHE IN
RO
THAT TALIBAND.
WE EXCDED TO IAN DEMORALIZINOR N
SECURITY FORCES. PTO R
LIISONER THEY DITHEM GNTO THE
FIGHT AGAINST THE PEOPHO  THEM.
T WITHDRAWAL OS
SO IT'S LIKE PHENOMENON.
THERE ARE A NUMBS R THE COLLAPSH
IGNORECENTRAROZING TAN
GOVERNMENT.
>> I MEAN, FR
AME RESULT HAVHA
TH?S BEFORE THAT DE
BECAUSE ITMSE THE S
AN AWFUL LOT POURED TO THIS. HA
ENCE
AMONG AFGHAN FORCE
STATE AN THE SRC
TS.
INT DIDN'THAPPEN OVERNIGHTL